talk about your career you know what  really matters is to use social  networking to its ultimate now because  really career moves are all about who  you know and when you know them that's  networking so the first thing you've got  to make sure is you get a great profile  set up on every platform you can that's  your base the other thing to remember  that's really important because I hire a  lot of people is I don't like to see  people moving or jumping more than once  every two years I always worry about it  when I see somebody's had five jobs in  36 months a bad sign career people look  at that they want to make sure that  you're able to fulfill your obligations  in one job before you move to another so  think about it you're building your  record online everywhere everybody knows  where you've been and where you want to  go use it well and good luck